House of the Dragon, Game of Thrones prequel
series that will air next year, is currently
filming on multiple locations and while filming
is happening, we have more actors and more
roles revealed and therefore we have more
character explaining to do. House of the Dragon,
although based on George RR Martin's Targaryen
history book Fire & Blood, will not feature
Targaryens only, but many other houses and
many other legendary figures from that time
period as well. While the cast for most of
the main characters was already announced
such as those for Viserys, Aegon, Daemon and
Rhaenyra Targaryen as well as for Otto and
Alicent Hightower, and Corlys Velaryion, one
of the most important characters in the story
has recently been announced by none other
than George R.R. Martin himself. Martin announced
the newest casting for House of the Dragon
and the role is for the Kingmaker, Ser Criston
Cole, who will be played by Fabien Frankel.
Martin gave the following description of the
character:
Cole plays a key role in the Dance of the
Dragons, as his nickname hints.
He’s the common-born son of the steward
to the Lord of Blackhaven. He’s got no claim
to lands or titles, all he has is an honor
and his skill with sword and lance. He’s
a challenger, a champion, cheered by the commons,
beloved of the ladies. He’s a lover (or
is he?), a seducer (or is he?), a betrayer
(or is he?), a breaker of hearts, and a maker
of kings. I can tell you that Ser Criston
Cole is one of those characters that you will
love and hate, which in my opinion is the
best type of character. Criston is a complex
character. He's one of the best knights of
his time, Lord Commander of the Kingsguard
and as the story progresses, he even becomes
the Hand of the King. At the beginning of
our story, he's loyal friend and protector
of Princess Rhaenyra, but later, upon some
mysterious events, he changes his allegiance
to Queen Alicent, Rhaenyra's enemy at King's
Landing court and later serves King Aegon
and fights against Rhaenyra during the entire
civil war. The Targaryen civil war is the
key event of this show as it's the key in
the history of House Targaryen, the Dance
of the Dragons which divided Westeros in two
and launched a huge war.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
It made House Targaryen much weaker, especially
because this conflict resulted with the extinction
of their dragons, while its numbers were at
its peak at the war's start. Miguel Sapochnik
and Ryan Condal will serve as showrunners
and executive producers. George R. R. Martin
will also serve as executive producer. Back
to Ser Criston Cole and his importance in
all of this. Ser Criston Cole was a knight
from House Cole. Made a member of King Viserys
I Targaryen's Kingsguard, eventually rising
to Lord Commander. Criston convinced Viserys's
son, Aegon, to claim the rule of the Seven
Kingdoms as his father lay dead. This led
to the Dance of the Dragons, a civil war between
Aegon II and his elder sister, Rhaenyra, whom
Viserys had long trained as his successor.
For this, he became known as Criston the Kingmaker.
He was an exceptionally skilled warrior, especially
with his morning star. Criston appears in
the history of House Targaryen by winning
a melee at the tourney at Maidenpool to celebrate
the ascension of Viserys I Targaryen, drawing
the attention of the royal court by knocking
Dark Sister from the hands of Prince Daemon
Targaryen with his morningstar. He gave the
victor's laurel to seven-year-old Princess
Rhaenyra Targaryen, whose favor he wore while
unhorsing Daemon in the joust, as well as
the famed Cargyll twins of the Kingsguard,
before being unhorsed by Lord Lymond Mallister.
Thereafter, King Viserys indulged Rhaenyra
by naming Criston her personal sworn shield.
In 105 AC, the twenty-three-year-old Criston
became a member of the Kingsguard, taking
the place of the legendary Ser Ryam Redwyne.
Cole wore Rhaenyra's favor in a tournament
in 111 AC where he unhorsed Ser Gwayne Hightower,
younger brother and champion to King Viserys's
second wife and queen, Alicent Hightower.
In 112 AC Ser Criston was still Rhaenyra's
champion and constant companion. Lord Commander
Ser Harrold Westerling died that year, and
Criston was named his successor to lead the
White Cloaks. It was rumored that Cole had
an affair with Rhaenyra in 113 AC. Septon
Eustace says that Ser Criston slipped into
Rhaenyra's bed-chamber to confess his love,
offering to escape the Kingsguard life with
her to one of the Free Cities where he would
pledge his sword to some merchant prince.
Eustace also says that Rhaenyra refused him,
saying a Targaryen was meant to be more than
a wife of a sellsword, and that if he could
forget his Kingsguard vows, he could forget
marriage vows. The royal fool Mushroom tells
a different tale - that Rhaenyra had been
practicing her enticements with her uncle,
Prince Daemon, so that she would lose her
maidenhead to Criston, a man she loved, rather
than her betrothed cousin, Laenor Velaryon.
She failed to seduce Ser Criston in White
Sword Tower, however, and the spurned princess
took solace in Ser Harwin "Breakbones" Strong.
This is why even if you read the book Fire
And Blood, on which this prequel is based,
you still will not know how most of the stories
play out because the book is not the actual
history, but the history that the author wrote
using many different statements. While the
author does offer few possible scenarios,
it doesn't mean any of them are true because
none of them were in the room with Rhaenyra
and Criston. It's just what they were told
that happened. Whatever the way of it, Cole
went from being her most loyal defender to
her bitterest foe, and Rhaenyra soon left
for Driftmark with Breakbones as her new sworn
shield.
In 114 AC, Ser Criston, as the Kingsguard
to King Viserys, attended the wedding of Rhaenyra
to Laenor, which included seven days of feasting
and jousting. Cole fought with Queen Alicent's
token, and during a melee left Breakbones
with a broken collarbone and shattered elbow,
thereafter prompting Mushroom to call him
"Brokenbones". Criston's morningstar also
cracked the helm of the Knight of Kisses,
Laenor's favorite Ser Joffrey Lonmouth, who
died from six days later. While many were
angered at Criston for this, including King
Viserys, Queen Alicent did not share their
displeasure and asked that he be made her
personal sworn shield. Cole thus became a
staunch supporter of Queen Alicent. Criston
tutored Alicent's fierce son, Prince Aemond
Targaryen to be a skilled swordsman, despite
Aemond having only one eye left after Rhaenyra's
son wounded him in a fight. Due to contradictory
sources, Criston's motives in supporting Aegon
II are unclear; some say that he acted from
ambition - as Aegon was more controllable
than his willful half-sister Rhaenyra; indeed
Aegon II eventually raised Criston to the
office of Hand of the King. However, some
say Rhaenyra rejected him, adding a personal
dimension to the conflict. Others allow Cole
nobler motives and claim he was defending
ancient Andal custom giving precedence to
sons over daughters OR that he did not wish
to see Rhaenyra's children who he believed
to be children born out of wedlock to inherit
the Iron Throne. In any event, many of the
lords of the realm were aware of Viserys's
wish to have Rhaenyra succeed him as House
Targaryen's first ruling queen, and stood
behind the princess after King Viserys died,
most notable of which were Corlys Velaryion
and Cregan Stark. Again due to contradictory
sources, during the meeting of Viserys's small
council after King Viserys's death in 129
AC, Cole is noted to have either slit the
throat or threw from a window, the aged Lord
Lyman Beesbury, the only member of the council
to support crowning Princess Rhaenyra instead
of Prince Aegon. The rest of the council were
allies of Ser Otto and Queen Alicent Hightower.
Criston later crowned Aegon II with the iron-and-ruby
crown of Aegon the Conqueror.
However, Rhaenyra, who was at Dragonstone
at the time of her father's death and Aegon's
coronation, refused to support Aegon, beginning
the great armed conflict which engulfed the
Seven Kingdoms and became known as the Dance
of the Dragons. As Rhaenyra's supporters gathered
their forces, Aegon II became frustrated with
his grandfather and Hand, Ser Otto Hightower,
and awarded the office to Criston Cole. The
Kingmaker's forces quickly took Duskendale
and Rook's Rest, the latter after a fierce
battle. When Prince Aemond Targaryen became
Protector of the Realm and Prince Regent because
of Aegon's injuries in the battle, Criston
remained the Hand. Aemond and the Kingmaker
led an army of 4,000 greens from King's Landing
to retake Harrenhal in the riverlands from
Prince Daemon Targaryen, who abandoned the
castle before Criston arrived and took this
opportunity to take King's Landing.
After hearing that Cregan Stark's Winter Wolfs
defeated his biggest allies, the Lannisters
in the battle by the Lakeshore, Aemond began
burning the riverlands and Cole marched his
remaining 3,600 greens south along the western
shore of the Gods Eye, intending to join with
the army of Lord Ormund Hightower. However,
the Kingmaker's forces were ambushed by the
Winter Wolves and river knights south of the
Gods Eye. Criston's forces were outnumbered
2 to 1 by the forces of the riverlands and
the north. Criston held a parley with the
Winter Wolf's commander Lord Roderick Dustin,
Ser Pate of Longleaf, and Ser Garibald Grey.
Criston offered to surrender but was refused
by three blacks. Upon this refusal, Ser Criston,
a famed knight who was also the Lord Commander
of the Kingsguard for Aegon II in addition
to being the King's Hand, prepared to fight
all three of his counterparts at once. Before
he could do so, however, the Kingmaker was
struck down by arrows fired by Red Robb Rivers
and two of his longbowmen. With Criston dead,
Lord Dustin sounded the charge of Winter Wolfs
and the river knights into Criston's now leaderless
army which quickly collapsed. Perhaps we could
end Criston's story with this quote about
him by Jaime Lannister. When Loras Tyrell
told him that the best Kingsguard heroes will
always be remembered, Jaime replied with "the
best and the worst. And a few who were a bit
of both. Like Criston Cole." Was Criston in
love with Rhaenyra who became her worst enemy
after she refused him or did he refuse her
and sided with Aegon, was Cole an honorable
knight or ambitious man with no morals, and
was he truly the best warrior of his time,
even better than Daemon himself? All of that
and more we'll see in the upcoming Game of
Thrones prequel series, House of the Dragon,
which airs next year on HBO. Thank you so
much for watching and I hope to see you in
the next one!